i say we talk about
superman being gay
bisexual that's a that's a safer
conversation
or you know the economy going down uh
you know energy talking about superman
because you were you were talking a lot
about masculinity and i think you're
saying the attack on masculinity and so
we actually have the story from npr
superman's son comes out as bisexual in
a new comic it's a big deal sort of now
first i will just say in no uncertain
terms
i don't i don't care to become a honest
i i saw this and i was like like it
doesn't affect my life i'm not going to
buy the comic i don't care if someone
made the comic if you like the comic
that's all the by all means and i hope
you enjoy it but i will tell you what
was really funny
i tweeted
so there was a you know a tweet about
this and i tweeted superman as gay like
as just like a point of observation that
was a great tweet but i'm like it didn't
mean anything i'm just like i'm like oh
yeah like that superman is gay and
because he's kissing a guy and and and
the left got mad at me
and i was like well hold on what did i
say that was offensive like it's
literally a picture of superman kissing
a dude he's bisexual yeah i get that lgb
but you know like i guess is that but
that's not why they were mad bisexual's
not gay that's probably why they were
mad because they interpreted gay as
meaning bad right they didn't tweet at
me tim you're wrong he's bisexual some
did the people who were mad they were
like they were posting memes as if i was
complaining about it as if i was angry
about it yes the perception of text man
there's very little why did they
perceive me just pointing out he's
kissing a guy and saying he's gay why do
they perceive that as an attacker it's a
different kind of cult worship they
think they have you elevated to a person
that's going to aggravate in their mind
so they assume that that's what you're
trying to not even do that you have
mastered you've mastered that that genre
i gotta say but what did i what i i
didn't even do any i honestly was not
planning or thinking anything i saw the
tweet and i was like superman's gay and
i tweeted it out
i was like it's a statement of fact okay
it's not he's bisexual but it's coming
from a wrong fact coming from you you
hardcore right wing extremist trump maga
psychopath if you say anything is gay
you mean it's bad not that they're
actually two men having sex
that's
that's how they perceive it so and you
know
he's not by either you were wrong oh
he's not he's queer okay oh they say by
now you've likely heard he's got that's
more offensive to me superman champion
of the oppressed man of steel the man of
tomorrow the last son of krypton the big
blue boy scout mr not a bird nor plain
himself okay that's all completely wrong
by the way this is his son uh queer all
of a sudden
uh the yeah the son of kell is not
pal-el so please guys get your comic
book stuff right they say we're not
talking about the classic original clark
kent blah blah blah we get it his son
jonathan kent whose precise backstory in
the comics has been so ruthlessly
pummeled by a series of reboots retcon
space missions time travel and rapid
aging as to render it so
incomprehensible that it sends even die
hards like me scurrying to the nearest
wiki did you guys know that pink
kryptonite turned superman gay what what
yeah well i thought kryptonite was green
there's a bunch of different colors of
kryptonite oh yeah the pink one turns
him gay i'm i'm that that's just wait
from like the 50s comics i'm pretty sure
sounds like a pentagon bio weapon yeah
um that they talked about discussing and
implementing in vietnam but that's
another story
uh i'm not eating
population deconstruction yeah here look
superman wiki pink kryptonite is a type
of kryptonite that seemingly turns
kryptonians homosexual it is unknown
what it would do to an already
homosexual kryptonian although one could
assume it would render them heterosexual
or just gay type of kryptonite only made
one appearance in the comics and was
used as a satire of the plots of the
silver age comic stories featuring some
strange new form of kryptonite obscenely
offensive okay so that's from new
versions that's not from the old version
uh this is from supergirl number 79 many
happy returns what year was this one
i don't i don't know i i don't know i i
genuinely i don't care about comic books
yeah but i understand why people do
you know these are like uh superheroes
or icons that would you know batman
francis inspire pe inspire you to like
you know superman never kills the
villain he arrests them and now
i guess the the is there a concern i
don't know what your opinion is on this
i don't know what your opinion on this
is jack about taking away the
traditional masculine role
at once i have the same reaction as you
do which is i don't care because i don't
think comics are really that relevant
but i do know that there are a lot of
people that read them and that the
cultural influences are important but at
this point man it's just like the ocean
is around us and the pot is boiling and
i really don't know it didn't it didn't
like
look it's like if this was the first
story that came out about the first
thing that was doing this maybe but it's
just like the million billion thing that
we've heard and so what i'm saying is
maybe i'm capitulating you know a little
bit my sensitivity has been diminished
to it but you know honestly it doesn't
really bother me but i do i do disagree
with the the ret conning right like the
rewriting of the stories new characters
yeah and just make a new character right
superman is superman his son well i
guess are they gonna set up the
storyline where clark kent gets upset by
this and he disowns the disowned super
boy or whatever no it would be like like
superman is super accepting and then lex
luthor gets mad or something you know uh
i did i did see an interesting critique
where someone said that superman has
always been the progressive anyway right
even even the original superman uh
character which i'm not familiar with i
don't remember the movies i don't read
the comics but i do recall there was
some instance in which he was like we
want to you know save everybody and help
everybody achieve this and bring you
know bring everybody up and you know
it's very progressive sort of for sort
of mindset i think culturally i also
think we're kind of defunct in many
different ways because it's like we just
keep repeating the same stories over and
over again and to your point make a new
character yeah make something new make
something interesting but also
scream is being redone home alone is
being redone yesterday two of those
trailers dropped i mean can't you think
of new movies here's how i imagine it
imagine a table like this and the dc
comics people are sitting there and
they're like eyes half glazed over
and then they're just like uh look guys
um
i gotta i got a masseuse waiting for me
can we just do something oh i know i
know um superman but but he's gay
all right run with it good meeting
everybody
bisexual right even better but luke like
um i hear what you're saying about about
queer rehashing is is boring and old but
there's only so many stories
and they usually involve archetypical
situations in your life like things that
everybody goes through there's coming of
age you have like 50 genders there's so
many different options here that you can
roll with there's meetings there's
meeting the love of your life
they did this remember the marvel comic
were safe they had safe space yeah yeah
new new mutants and it was yeah it
crashed and burned they pulled it but
but i was looking to get an original
copy of it i can't find it oh that'd be
awesome
i'm gonna send one if you guys can find
coming of age meeting your girl uh
having kids getting divorced uh getting
your new job having your parents die
having your spouse die
these are these are stories that
everyone can relate to so there's always
going to be stories about that over and
over and over and over and over again uh
i will say uh might have a daughter and
you know you know crucify me for letting
my daughter watch disney but i will tell
you that descendants is actually pretty
good the descendants movie is about like
the kids of the original disney
characters and they're all their hijinks
and uh you know the the music is good
there's a lot of very crazy subliminal
messaging in disney movies um we can't
even talk about it here i don't even
know walt was apparently very it was the
new warriors not the new mutants the new
warriors
yeah they had safe space and snowflake
yeah all right that did that was that
they actually get released because i
remember tweeting about that i tweeted
about the characters and all this stuff
new warriors subscribe this is the new
new warriors they're remaking the new
warriors here and they they ended up
scrapping it because it was a little too
sj are you sure yes is this right it's
from what i heard is it right here man
if you can get that please do it's 200
270 boxes that's pretty pricey whoa
there it is wait no ten bucks okay
probably get like five of those
price anchoring like crazy
wait wait i can order a thousand
please don't
you know my thoughts on this are that
creative expression you can do whatever
you want with creativity i don't know
why these particular people are in
control of the superman franchise right
now i have to buy 25 apparently both
books definitely do it
minimum order is 25 i hope i hope that
everyone gets one in the house i hope
they don't make sexuality the topic of
the superman comic because it's never
been the purpose of superman his
sexuality was never the spotlight but if
people feel that being bisexual queer
gay or whatever
makes it makes sexuality
there's a love story but that wasn't the
his sexuality wasn't part of it it was
about the love between lois and clark
and maybe that was just comment that was
his heteronormativity bro and maybe
someone's taking a picture of him
kissing a man out of context and making
it a bigger deal than it is maybe the
comic it's not big a big part of the
plot he just loves this guy
so let's find out but
i
i i made that's a bigger deal than i
realized for the queer people that that
is a big part of the plot of being alive
and being real and that
what actually i take offense to and
hopefully we don't get banned for this
but like i like
queer is a political perspective now
queer means to you can be
straight and be queer
i didn't know this i'm learning this but
queen actually this is why where are you
learning this jack you're
technically wrong that's one of those
pit traps where you're offensive no
matter what you say about it oh well of
course something like women yeah yeah of
course it's offensive but like my point
is that to be queer is now a political
position which means to blur boundaries
on purpose but but it's not acceptable
like like the the use of the term is
acceptable not acceptable at the same
time well right i'm not using a
derogatory no no no no no in any context
like that so women can't you can't say
queer i think you can't it's lgbtq it's
right in there you can't know what i'm
saying is the way you're describing it
as a political thing and you can be
straight but be queer that's not true
it's one of those things where you'll
see some people say then as soon as
someone else has it it's offensive and
you get banned for it
so like like wimmickson for instance was
w-o-m-x-n
you know women but they say we're mixing
and then they said this is the new
inclusive term and then immediately the
the organization that was using it
started getting canceled and attacked
and then you have you have actively at
the same time the word we're mixing is
both simultaneously inoffensive
offensive and the appropriate term right
which means no matter what you say they
will come after you and then they will
wage a campaign against you
when it comes to cancel culture there's
no logic for the most part it's what can
i do to get this person hurt
and so they've created circumstances
where no matter what you're falling into
a trap there it's a trap okay but but
there are
kids teenagers who identify as queer who
are attracted to people of the opposite
sex and who also believe that they are
the gender matching the sexuality that
they were assigned at their birth
and and then there's nobody
and there's no way for you to properly
address it without getting banned well
then i i'm not addressing woke pit traps
yeah i mean look at crowder that's what
we're talking about steven crowder gets
gets nuked for talking about a news
story
these are treacherous times we live in
my friend but this is why we set up
timcast.com because the very least
you know that's that's the way i put it
when it comes to like new york and the
vaccine mandate stuff if there was a
business that had a speakeasy in the
back that was operating and saying you
know
yeah yeah go in the back we're not
mandating whatever i'd be like they're
clearly in opposition they're clearly
standing up against it or they could
sell ownership they can be like buy one
share the company you can do whatever
you want on the property there you go
that could work so you got to have we
got to have a space a backup space but i
don't know man there's there's there's
simultaneously reasons to be optimistic
reasons to be pessimistic you see there
was a story about the republicans
flipping a democratic stronghold seat in
iowa yeah i saw that moving one step
closer to taking control of many
different legislative bodies in the
different states and with joe biden's
failing approval rating we also have uh
an organ two organizations that raise
money for state level republicans record
fundraising kevin mccarthy record
fundraising like 60 million bucks
so i mean
i think those are good indications of a
red wave that could be optimistic if
republicans did anything yeah otherwise
it's just kind of like yeah good for
them i guess but what are we gonna get
out of it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time